Evet, herkese selamlar, sevgili 9.
sınıflar. Ne haber, nasılsınız? Umarım
keyifler yerinde, her şey yolunda
gidiyordur. Evet, evlat olsa sevilmez
konu başlıklı
derslerimize devam ediyoruz açıkçası.
Algoritmanın 3. dersine geldik. İlk iki
derste ne yaptık? Önce ilk dersimizde
algoritmayı tanıdık biliyorsun. İkinci
derste biraz daha şova kalktık artık
böyle daha detaylara gittik. Öğeler
mevzularından falan bahsetmiştim
biliyorsun. Orada çok güzel bir taktik
verdik sana yurt dışı
tatille ilgili. Şimdi bu dersimizde de
yine acayip işlerden bahsedeceğiz.
Mantık ve bağlaçlar. Öncelikle bu dersin
temeli %95'ini oluşturacak kısım. Mantık
ve bağlaçlar, niceleyiciler. Bunları
nasıl kullanacağız, bundan bahsedeceğim
algoritma içerisinde. Ve tabii ki de
ondan sonra da bir Kadane problemi
teoremi var ki
oralarda sular biraz bulanıklaşacak.
Dolayısıyla çok dikkatli bir şekilde
dersi dinlemeni istiyorum. Tabii ki de
neredeyiz? 27. dersteyiz. Yani 9. sınıf
Mortosuncuk'tan video ders kitabımızdan
ilerliyoruz. 27. dersimizde de yine
süpersonik bir şekilde sayfalarımızı
dolduracağız. Birebir özel ders
formatında. Bence hala almadıysan kitabı
edinip bu dersten itibaren devam et.
Çünkü içerisinde pekiştirme soruları,
yazılı uygula soruları vesaire hani size
de ödev olarak bıraktığım, çözüm
videoları olan sorular da var.
Hem kendinizi pekiştirmiş hem de yazılı
örnek soru sorularıyla aslında bir
sonraki yazılımıza da hazırlanmış
oluruz. Ama en en önemlisi kitabın tabii
ki de ilk 200 sayfasını boş
bırakmayacaksın. 10. sınıfa geçerken bir
9. sınıfı da
tekrar etmek gerekecek. Çünkü açıkçası
özellikle mesela fonksiyonlar var. E 10.
sınıfta onun üstüne koya koya
ilerleyeceğiz. Dolayısıyla tekrar
etmekte çok çok büyük fayda olduğunu
söyleyebilirim. Hani ister Haziran'da
yap, ister Ağustos'ta yap. Ama 10.
sınıfa geçmeden bir 9 tekrarı bence şart
diyebilirim. Onun dışında hocam iyi hoş
da bizim matematik temeli zayıf diyorsan
da Haziran ayında şu arkadaşla kampımıza
başlıyoruz. Haberiniz olsun. Mat Kor 14
günde sıfırdan matematik video ders
kitabıyla tamamen sıfırdan matematiğin
şöyle bir içinden geçeceğiz. Temelini
vereceğiz. Zemini gerçekten sağlam bir
yere oturtacağız. Mat Kor çekirdekte
yani kor ne demek? Çekirdek. Matematiğin
çekirdeğine indik bu kitapta.
Dolayısıyla da 14 günde süpersonik bir
kamp planlıyoruz. Ne zaman? Yazın
yapacağız Haziran'da. Takvim netleşince
onları da duyururuz, paylaşırız.
Şimdiden kitabı edinip istersen sen de
başlayabilirsin. Böyle çıtır çerez.
Amacımız elimiz alışsın, matematikle
aramızdaki o buzları eritelim istiyoruz.
Anlaştık mı? Haydi o zaman ne yapalım?
Ders ekranımıza şöyle ben seni bir
alayım. Alamadık mı? Dur, gelmedin.
Evet, klasikleşmiş tablet arızalarımızı
da giderdikten sonra 27. dersimizde
başlıyoruz. Gençler, yaklaşalım mı şöyle
ve başlıyorum.
Şimdi öncelikle mantık bağlaçları
dediğimiz mevzu aslında şu, önermeler
arasındaki ilişkileri belirlerken
niceleyiciler önermelerin kapsamını
tanımlıyorlar. Şimdi bu böyle havada
kalacak cümleler ama birazdan ben sana
mevzuyu çok netleştireceğim. Nesneleri
veya kişileri sınıflandıran
problemlerde, çizge veya şifreleme
işlemlerinde bu bağlaç ve niceleyicileri
sıklıkla kullanacağız. Şimdi
Türkçedeki bağlaçlardan bahsetmiyoruz.
Birazcık tabii oraya da göz kırpan
durumlar var ama bizim mevzumuz
matematiksel olarak biz bunları nasıl
kullanacağız? Şimdi bağlaçlarımız şu
kardeşlerimiz. Eskiden bunlar zaten 9.
sınıfın biliyorsun ilk ya da bilmiyorsun
nereden bileceksin ilk konusuydu
müfredat değişmeden önce mantık başlığı
altında. Hepsini detaylı tek tek uzun
uzun anlatıyorduk ama yeni müfredatta
bir tık daha yüzeysel geçiliyor. Hepsi
verilmiyor ve kitabınızda yani yeni
Maarif modelde olduğu kadar ile şimdi
anlatacağım. Birincisi V bağlacı. Haydi
başlıyoruz. Ne demekmiş V bağlacı?
Hocam, ne işe yarar bu? Şimdi iki veya
daha fazla önermenin, bunu şöyle de
düşünebilirsin. Yani iki veya daha fazla
cümle. Yani önerme dediğimiz şey, ıı,
matematiksel bir, ıı, mevzu karşına
gelecek. İki veya daha fazla, biz iki
ile kalacağız, merak etme. Burada
hepsinin doğru olup olmadığını kontrol
eder diyor. Zaten V bağlacı nedir? Iı,
annen seni bakkala gönderdi. Bak, ekmek
ve süt al dedi. Ne yaparsın? İkisini
alırsan o iş olur, değil mi? O iş
doğruya gider. Ama ikisinden birini
almazsan ne yaparsın? Ya da ikisini
birden almazsan naneyi yersin.
Dolayısıyla V bağlacı aslında bir, ıı,
iki tarafın da olması koşuludur. Zaten
onu söylüyoruz, bak. Hepsinin doğru olup
olmadığını kontrol eder. V bağlacı
budur. Sembolü de şöyle ters V
şeklindedir. Oradan anla mevzunun ne
kadar önemli olduğunu. V bağlacını ters
yapmışlar. Yani bu kadar dikkat çekmeye
çalışıyorlar. Herkes doğru olacak diyor.
Anlaştık mı?
İkinci bağlacım veya bağlacı. Şimdi
burada bak Y harfi var ya, bu ne demek
biliyor musun? Yumuşak kalpli demek.
Yani yumuşak kalpli bir anne gibi
anlatırdık biz bunu eskiden. Iı,
ben öyle anlatırdım tabii. Bizim gibi
kırık baş hoca olmadığı için. Şimdi veya
bağlacını gerçekten öyle düşüneceksin.
Yumuşak kalpli. Neden?
Çünkü mevzu şu. Burada yine iki veya
daha fazla önerme karşına geliyor. Veya
bağlacı varsa en az birinin doğru olması
yetiyor.
Şimdi annen sana dedi ki, git bakkala.
Ekmek veya süt al dedi. E sen şimdi
burada ekmek alırsan anneden bir gülücük
onay alırsın, değil mi?
Iı, süt alırsan sadece, e orada da onay
alırsın. Çünkü anne öyle demiş. Ekmek
veya süt al demiş. Ama ikisini birden de
alırsan yine bu, herkes mutlu. Yine bir
sıkıntı olmaz. Ama hiçbirini almazsan
anne sana basar tekmeyi, tekrar bakkala
gönderir, değil mi? Yani, olay
yanlış sonuçlanır. Demek ki veya bağlacı
neymiş? En azından biri doğru olursa
çalışıyormuş. En azından biri bak. Ve
bağlacı neydi? Bunu da biz böyle
kaşlarını çatmış, sert baba gibi
anlatırız. Yani, kaşlar çatık, her şeyi
doğru istiyor. Baba 99 aldım. Neden 100
almadın lan diye böyle atarlanan babalar
var ya, onun gibi düşünün. Herkes, her
şey, hepsi, tüm önermeler doğru olacak
ve bağlacında. Kaşlar çatık çünkü.
Veya bağlacı yumuşak kalpli anne. En
azından birini yapsan tamam diyor.
İkisini de yaparsan o şahane, sıkıntı
yok. O da tamam. Ama hiçbir şey
yapmıyorsan, anne de artık yani biz
her şeyin bir sınırı var.
Ya da bağlacına geldim. Şimdi dikkat. Ya
da bağlacında
iki önermeden yalnızca birinin doğru
olup olmadığını kontrol ediyor. Şimdi ya
da bağlacı şöyle çalışıyor. Yani, bu ya
da bu şeklinde. Yani, ikisinden yalnızca
biri olacak.
İki tane mesela, bunu da birazcık eee
liseli ergen tripleriyle anlatmıştık
önceki yıllarda. Mevzu şu. Hani,
bunu ya da bunu
eee yani sen iki tane şey sunuyorsun,
hediye götürüyorsun mesela. Arkadaş
diyor ki, "Onu ya da bunu istiyorum."
Sen diyorsun ki, "İkisini de al."
"Hayır." diyor ya. "İkisini de
almayacağım." diyor. "O zaman hiçbirini
vermem." diyorsun mesela. "Onu da
olmaz." diyor. Ona da üzülüyor. O zaman
ya bir tanesi şunu vereceksin ya da bunu
vereceksin yani, ikisinden birini demek
bu.
Ya da bağlacı
yalnızca birini istiyor. Bak, veya
bağlacı en az birini doğru istiyordu. Ya
da bağlacı yalnızca birini doğru
istiyor. Tamam? Yani, veya bağlacında
ikisi de doğru olabilir. İki önerme de
doğruysa sonuç seni doğruya götürür. Ama
ya da bağlacında sadece yalnızca biri
doğru olacak. E hocam ikisini de doğru
verelim ne olur? Olmaz. Bu seni yanlışa
götürüyor işte. Yani sonuç olarak hatalı
bir sonuca ulaşıyorsun. Anlatabildim mi?
Bu arada veya bağlacının sembolü normal
V harfi, ya da bağlacına da yine
matematikçi amcalar çok kasmamışlar
biliyorsun bunlar tembel amcalar.
V harfinin altına şöyle çizik atmışlar.
Sadece bu kadar.
Anlatabildim mi? Bak V bağlacı herkes
doğru istiyor. Sağını solunu herkes
doğru olacak yoksa
hatalı çıkarsın.
Veya bağlacı yumuşak kalp bende. En az
birini doğru istiyor.
İkisi de hatalıysa, ikisi de yanlış
söylüyorsan
o hatalı sonuç verir. Ama en azından
birini doğru yaptıysan tamam diyor.
İkisini de doğru yapabilirsin.
Sadece bunu yapabilirsin doğru ya da
sadece bunu doğru yaparsın sıkıntı yok.
Ya da bağlacı yalnızca birini istiyor.
İki önerme var. Ya sadece bu doğru
olacak ya da sadece bu doğru olacak.
İkisi birden doğru olamaz. İkisi birden
yanlış olamaz.
Kapiş? O zaman ise bağlacı diyelim.
Şimdi bir koşulun sağlanması durumunda
belirli bir komutun yerine getirilmesini
sağlar. Aslında bu
if clause'lu cümle dediğimiz mevzular.
Hani ise şudur gibi bir durum var. Çok
detaya girmiyorum. İsenin aslında daha
detayları var mantık konu başlığında.
Dilersen geçmiş müfredattaki mantık
videolarını izleyebilirsin ama gerek
yok. Kitabınız ne kadar aldıysa,
müfredat ne kadar girdiyse ben de o
kadar
kurcalayacağım. Haberin olsun. Şimdi iki
tane de niceleyicimiz var. Dört tane
bağlaç attık yeter.
Yeter. Her şeyin bir sınırı var. Bir de
niceleyicilerimiz var iki tane. Bunlar
da yine matematik matematikçede
matematikçede çok kullanılan
arkadaşlarımız sembollerimiz. Bunlar
sembol aslında. Ben sana şu an
matematikçeyi anlatıyorum. Yani amca
oraya V yazmayacak. Şu sembolü
kullanacak. Mesela ise yazmayacağız
artık, şunu kullanacağız. Tamam? Mevzu
bu yani.
Şimdi
yani sen şu sembolü gördüğünde ne
anlaman gerektiğini anlattım şu an.
Şimdi iki tane de niceleyicimiz var, o
da şu. Birincisi her niceleyicisi bir
önermenin herhangi bir öğe için doğru
olduğunu ifade edecek.
Her yani herhangi bir şey, ne verirsen
ver, herhangi bir şey ver, doğru gibi
kabul edeceğiz. Yani şöyle her x mesela
elemanıdır reel sayı dediğimde buradaki
x'ler x'i ne seçersen seç reel sayı
olması gerekiyormuş. Anlatabildim mi?
Ama bazı niceleyicisi en az bir öğe için
doğru. Mesela sen bir denklem yazdın,
bana dedin ki hani bu denklemde bence en
az bir tane x vardır doğal sayı olan
mesela. Bu ne demek? En az bir tane
doğal sayı senin işine yarıyor demek
mesela. Ya da bunu cümle kurarken bu
sembolü kullanacağız. Ya da bundan sonra
sen bu sembolü görünce nasıl
okuyacakmışsın?
En az bir tane x
reel sayıda yani reel sayı olarak, reel
sayı kümesine ait, reel sayılara dahil
en az bir tane x demekmiş. Eğer şu
sembol ters A harfine döndü mü ne
oluyormuş? Her oluyormuş. Yine
matematikçi amcalar kasmamış. Ulan ters
A nereden aklınıza geliyor ya? Ters A
yapmışlar hani A'yı çevirelim. Bazıda da
E'yi çevirmişler, ters yazmışlar. Tamam?
Hadi bir tane de soru çözelim de şöyle
bir kafamıza iyice yatsın. Aşağıda ne
var? Tabloda bir sınıftaki öğrenciler
bir deneme sınavında sayısal, sözel
bölümlerde çözdükleri doğru cevap
sayılarını vermişler. Mesela Alper ne
yapmış?
Alper eee sayısalda 36 yapıştırmış,
sözelde de 26 yapıştırmış gibi gibi
öğrenciler var. Burada doğru sayıları
verilmiş. Soru şu. Aşağıdaki koşulu
içeren sözel ifadeleri mantık bağlaçları
ve niceleyicilerle ifade edeceğiz.
Sonra da koşulu sağlayan öğrencileri
bulacağız.
Şimdi önce teknik çalışalım. Yani biz
bunları mantık bağlaçları ve
niceleyicilerle önce bir ifade edelim.
Yani dersimiz şu an ne? Türkçeden
matematikçeye çevireceğiz. Tamam? Şimdi
A'da ne diyor? Sayısal doğru cevap
sayısı 28'den fazla, sözel doğru cevap
sayısı 34'ten az olan öğrenciler.
Aradaki bağlacım ne? Ve bağlacı. Yani şu
an seçeceğim öğrenciler
sayısalda, sayısalda 28'den fazla
ve
ve bak sayısalda 28'den fazla yapacaksın
1. şart, 2. şartı da sağlayacaksın.
2.'si ne? Sözelde de 34'ten az
yapacaksın. Şimdi ben bunu nasıl
söyleyeceğim sana? Yani matematikçeye
nasıl çevireceğim? Şöyle çeviriyorum.
Diyorum ki
sayı yazalım. Uzun uzun bana sayısal
yazdırmayın bu yaşta. 28'den fazla. Ne
demek 28'den fazla? E büyüktür 28 demek
değil mi? 28'den fazla araya ne
koyuyorum? Ve bağlacı koyuyorum ve sözel
için de ne diyorum? 34'ten az yani
küçüktür 34 diyeceğim. Şimdi bu iki
koşulu da sağlayan öğrencileri,
students, bunları bulacağız. Kimmiş bu
yavrucaklar?
Şimdi sayısalı 28'den fazla mesela Alper
buraya girdi. Ama sözelin de 34'ten az
olmasını istiyorum. Oldu mu? Oldu. O
zaman ben Alper'i aldım gençler.
Hayırlısı uğurlusu olsun.
Diğer öğrencimize bakalım. Buse
sayısalda 30. Aa tamam Buse sen
bana sayısalda uyuyorsun. Peki sözelin
kaç senin? 32. 34'ten az. Aha ben
Buse'yi de aldım gençler. Buse de oldu
bana. Haydi devam edelim. Şimdi
Ceren'deyim. Sayısal 28'den fazla tik
attım. Sözel 34'ten fazla. Hayır 34'ten
az istiyordum Ceren, ne yaptın ya?
Geçiyorum bunu. Şimdi de çok da polemiğe
girmeyelim Ceren'le. Duygu'ya geldim.
28'den fazla sayısallı tutturdu.
Sözelini bakıyorum, 30. 34'ten az
istiyordum, tamam. Ben
Ceren'i alamadım, Duygu'yu aldım. Geldim
Ersin Koç'a. Ersin Koç tam sınırda.
28'den büyük istiyordum. Ersin seni
üzgünüm ama alamıyorum. 28'den büyük
olacaktın. Geçtim. Fehmi'ye geldim.
28'den büyük değil bir kere, geçtim.
Bak, ve bağlacını direkt geçebiliyorum.
Anlatabildim mi? Çünkü ikisini de kesin
sağlaması gerekiyor. Sağlanmayan,
herhangi birini sağlamıyorsan, dızıt,
almıyorum seni.
Şimdi Fehmi'yi de alamadık. Gül
sayısaldan kurtardı.
28'in üstü. Sözelde ne yapmış? 26,
34'ten. Gül'ü aldım. Tamam, Gül, sen
bizdensin. Gel, ekibe katıl. Ve de
Halit'e geldim. Halit sayısaldan
istediğimiz gibi, sözelde de istediğimiz
gibi. O zaman Halit'i de ben alırım,
yüksek müsaadelerinizle.
Şimdi geçiyorum B'ye. Sayısaldan en az
30 diyor. Ne yazacağım gençler? En az 30
ne demek? 30, 31, 32, 33, öyle gidecek,
değil mi? En az 30. O zaman sayısal için
büyük eşittir 30 diyeceğim.
Arada veya bağlacım var. Veya bağlacımı
koydum oraya. Ve ne istiyorsun? Erkek
öğrenci istiyorsun. Çok güzel. Şimdi
bak.
Arada veya bağlacı var. Veya bağlacı
neydi? İkisinden bir tanesi de olsa
olur. İkisi aynı anda sağlamak zorunda
değilsiniz, tamam mı?
Şimdi o yüzden ben şunu yapacağım.
Öncelikle sayısal
30'u geçen, 30 ve 30 üstündeki
arkadaşları alacağım. Kim bunlar? Alper,
şurada netlerin yanında yapalım. Alper
geçmiş.
Tamam, Buse bana uyuyor. Ceren, olur.
Duygu, seni de alalım. Eee, Gül, 30'u
geçiyor. Halit de 30'u geçiyor. E tamam,
ben sizi alırım gençler. O zaman ne
yapıyorum? Alper, Buse, Ceren, Duygu.
Bunlar sayısallığı 30'dan geçtiği için
alıyorum. Eee, kimi alacağım başka? Gül
ve Halit'i de alacağım. Ama eee, eğer
erkekse de alabilirim. Mesela Ersin,
erkek kontenjanından beni yakaladı.
Ersin'i de alacağım. Fehmi de yine erkek
kontenjanından beni yakaladı.
Dolayısıyla Fehmi'yi de ne yapıyoruz?
Alıyoruz. Tamam, hepsini almış olduk.
Şimdi geldim sözel bölümüme. Şimdi sözel
bölümde
sözel bölümde olalım. C şıkkına geldim.
Sözel bölümden doğru cevap sayısı en çok
32.
Şimdi ya, önce bir ne yapalım bunu?
Mantık bağlaçları ve niceleyicilerle
matematikçe yazalım.
Sözel bölüm, şöyle sözel diyorum, tamam
mı? Doğru cevap sayısı en çok 32. Yani
ben ne istiyorum? 32 olabilir, ama küçük
olsun. Ya da bağlacı var. Ya da
bağlacımı koydum. Bu sefer ne istiyorum?
Kız istiyorum. Şimdi gençler, çok çok
dikkat ediyoruz. Çünkü ya da bağlacı ne
istiyordu? İkisinden sadece biri doğru
doğru olacak.
Şimdi o yüzden ben kızlardan başlayayım.
Tamam mı? Kız öğrencileri şöyle bir
işaretliyorum. Öncelik tanıdığım Buse,
Ceren, Duygu, Ersin, Fehmi, Gül. Eee,
tamam, bunlar kız öğrencilerimiz.
Kız kontenjanından ben bunları
alabilirim. Ama bak, şuraya da
sataştılarsa, sözelde 32'den az 32 ve
32'den azsa almam. İkisini de sağlamış
olurlar. Hayır, ben onları istemiyorum.
Şimdi Buse'ye bakalım. Buse sözelde ne
yaptın? 32 yaptın. Olmadı be.
Yapma be Buse. İkisini de sağlattın.
İptal. Buse, çiziktirdim. Şimdi Ceren'e
geliyorum. Ceren ne yapmış? 36 yapmış.
Ben ne istiyordum? 32'den az istiyordum.
Tamam, 32'den az kontenjanına giremedi.
Bu Ceren daha çok yapmış çünkü. Sadece
kız kontenjanında burayı sadece
doğrulattı. Bak, burası iptal. Sen
göremiyorsun tabii oralara. Şöyle bak.
Sözel kısım şurası iptal, tamam mı?
Sözele çarpı. Kıza tik. Tamam, ben kız
kontenjanından alırım. Kimi alıyorum?
Ceren'i alabiliyorum. O zaman ben şuraya
Ceren'i aldım.
Şimdi Duygu'ya bakalım. Duygu 30 yapmış.
Bir kere Duygu zaten kız kontenjanından
giriyordu. 30 yaptığı için bu
kontenjandan da girdi. İkisine de tik
attı Duygu. Bize gelmez. Ya da
bağlacında sadece birini istiyordum.
Duygu da iptal.
Hemen Buse'yi çizdik. Duygu'yu da
çizelim. Bunları almayacağım. Gül'e
bakıyorum. Şimdi Gül zaten kız
kontenjanından girdi. Yani kız
önermeme tik attım.
Ama Gül ne yapmış? 26 yapmış. Buraya da
tik atıyor Gül. Olmaz Gül. İkisine de
tik at de tik attığın için seni de
almıyorum. O da iptal.
Şimdi gelelim diğerlerine. Şimdi bak.
Diğerleri erkek. Zaten kız kontenjanına
buraya zaten komple çarpı atıyoruz
erkekler için. Sadece sözele bakacağım.
Ama onu da doğrulatmaları lazım. Çünkü
yalnızca birinin doğru olması gerekiyor.
Şimdi Alper girer mi? Alper 26'yla
girer. Çünkü diğerine tik attı Alper.
Sözel 32'den az. Alper'i aldım.
Eee, Ersin'e bakalım. Ersin 30
yapıştırmış. Olur, Ersin'i de alırım.
Kızdan giremedi. Orası hatalı. Ama
sözelden girdi. O birinci önermemde
doğruyu yakaladı. Ersin'i aldım.
Fehmi'ye bakıyorum. 20 yapmış. Fehmi'yi
de alırım.
Halit 32 yapmış. Halit'i de alırım.
Mevzu tam olarak işte bu şekilde.
Şimdi birinci soru nakavt. O zaman haydi
gelelim ikinci sorumuza. Buralar biraz
daha tıkır tıkır geçeceğimiz yerler
gençler. Hemen ikinci soruya bakıyorum.
Yine ne yapacağız? Sözel ifade verecek
bize. Yani bunu yazılığınızda da
muhtemelen çıkacaktır. Bunu bağlaçlar ve
niceleyicilerle sen ne yazacaksın?
Matematikçesini yazacaksın aslında. Yani
Türkçeden matematikçeye çeviri
yapacağız. Birinciden başlayalım.
Matematik dersinin sınavından matematik
dersinin sınavından en az 60 ve
ve diyor Türkçe dersi sınavından en çok
70 alanlar. Ben bunu nasıl yazarım?
Birinci parantezime matematik en az 60.
En az 60. 60'ı kabul ediyorum ama üstü
istiyorum. Dolayısıyla büyük eşittir 60
diyeceğim. Arada ve bağlacım var. Türkçe
dersi için de en çok 70 istiyorum.
Dolayısıyla küçük eşit 70'i
yapıştıracağım geçeceğim. Sadece bunu
yazıp geçiyoruz. Burada bir öğrenci
seçme durumu yok. Tarih dersine bakalım.
50 ve 50'den fazla.
Şimdi tarih için 50 ve 50'den fazla
büyük eşittir 50 şeklinde gösteririm.
Arada veya var. Veya bağlacımı
yapıştırdım. Fizik dersimi yazıyorum. En
az 80. En az 80 ne? 80, 85, 90. Bunları
istiyoruz. O zaman fizik için büyük
eşittir ne dedim? 80'imi yapıştırdım.
Geldim üçüncüye. Bu sefer kimya
konuşacağız. 30 ve 30'dan az. Hmm. Ne
yapalım? K diyelim. Küçük eşittir 30.
Arada ya da bağlacı var. Coğrafya için
de ne istiyoruz? C diyelim ona da. 40 ve
40'tan fazla. Büyük eşittir 40. Yani ne
yapıyoruz? Sözelci öğrencileri
seçeceğiz. Coğrafyayı 40'tan fazla,
kimyayı 30'dan az alanlar. Tamam?
Mevzu bu. Matematikçe yazdım geçtim.
Haydi üçüncü soru. Şimdi A B sıfırdan
farklı tam sayılar olmak üzere bir
algoritma ya ait akış şeması verilmiş.
Tamam şemayı görüyoruz. Buna göre
ifadelerden hangilerinin doğru olduğunu
bulacağız. Hadi gel bakalım.
Şimdi algoritmam başlıyor. Bak A ve B
gir demiş. A küçük 0 evet diyorsan yeşil
yap ekranı ya da ekran mavi çıkıyor
vesaire vesaire. Şimdi gel birinciye bir
bakalım.
Birincide bağlacım veya bağlacı. Yumuşak
kalp. İkisinden biri olsa olur. Şimdi
birinciye bakıyorum A küçük 0 tamam ben
bunu doğru kabul edeyim.
A küçük 0'a evet dersem ekran yeşil
oluyor mu? Oluyor. O zaman ekran yeşil
olur ha ben buraya doğru derim.
Birinci öncül doğru.
Bitti.
Polemiğe gerek yok. Detaya girmeye gerek
yok. Burada olayı kapat.
Çünkü veya bağlacı böyle bir bağlaç. En
az bir tane doğru buluyorsan bitti.
Şimdi ikinci öncüle gel.
Burada V bağlacı var. Bak kaşlar
çatılmış. Sinirli asabi baba. İkisini de
istiyor.
Şimdi sen buraya bakıyorsun A büyük 0.
Şimdi A küçük 0'a o zaman ben ne
diyeceğim? Hayır diyeceğim. Buradan
çıkmam lazım. B'ye de büyük 0 demem
lazım. B büyük 0'a da evet diyeceğiz
yani. O zaman ekran ne oluyormuş? Mavi
oluyormuş. Hadi oradan sarı değil
maviymiş.
Tamam?
Mevzu anlaşıldı değil mi? V bağlacı
olduğu için.
Geldim üçüncüye. Ya da bağlacındayız.
Şimdi ya da bağlacı neydi? Ya sen doğru
olacaksın ya da sen doğru olacaksın
değil mi? Fakat her durumda sağlanması
gerekiyor ki ekran mavi olsun.
Yani mesela ben buna doğru buna yanlış
diyerek bir bakacağım. Bakalım ekran ne
oluyor? Sonra bir de buna doğru buna
yanlış diyerek bakacağım ekran ne
oluyor?
Her durumda ekranın mavi olması lazım.
Anlatabildim mi? Yani şuradaki önermeler
her zaman doğru olması lazım.
İçlerinde ama
içlerine baktım detaya baktım da
parantez içinde bir tanesi doğru bir
tanesinin yanlış çıkması gerekiyor.
Tamam?
Şimdi o zaman hadi gel bakalım. A küçük
0 demiş. Bak, bunu doğru kabul edelim. A
küçük 0'a evet dersem ekranı ne yapar?
Yeşil yapar. Bak. Şurayı bir
temizleyeyim. Bak şimdi, yola çıktım. A
küçük 0'a evet dediğim anda ekran yeşil
olur. Ekran mavi olur cevabı zaten
yanlış patladı.
Değil mi? Ekran yanlış olur cevabı
patladı. Yani bu 1, bu 0'ken ekran mavi
falan olmuyor.
Yeşil oluyor. Tamam?
Ha diyeceksin ki hocam ama bak büyük 0'ı
kabul yani bunu yanlış, bunu doğru kabul
edince oluyor. Bir bakalım. Bunu yanlış
kabul edelim gençler. A küçük 0'ı yanlış
kabul edelim. Yani A küçük 0'a biz
yanlış dedik. Hayır. B büyük 0'a ise
doğru dedik. Evet, ekran mavi oldu.
Hocam dediği oldu. Tamam ama bu yanlış,
bu doğruyken oldu. Tam tersinde bu
doğru, bu yanlışken
olmadı.
Olacak mıydı? Olmak zorundaydı. Tamam? O
yüzden ya da bağlacında da işleri
yapamadık. Yanlış [homurdanır] dedik.
Dolayısıyla sadece birinci öncül doğru
olur.
Kapiş? Haydi o zaman geçtim. 4. soru.
Şimdi buraları bence seri geçeriz. Şimdi
bak A, B gerçek sayı olmak üzere demiş.
A x B 0 eşitliği verilmiş.
Biliyorsun değil mi?
İki sayının çarpımı 0 mevzusunun nasıl
gerçekleştiğini biliyorsun. En az birisi
0 olacak.
En az biri dedim. Ah! Acaba hangi
bağlaçla bunu yazacağız? Mantık
bağlaçları ve durumlarını gösteren
ifadeyi demiş ki sembol
lerle, sembolik dil ile ifade ediniz.
Şimdi ben ne diyeceğim? Bir kere sen
bana A, B'yi tanımlamışsın. Ben bir kere
buraya yazarım. A, B elemanıdır reel
sayı mevzusunu önce bir yazarım. Gerçek
sayı demiş çünkü. Tamam?
Bunun için, bunun için
bana bir şey veriyor.
İşte a çarpı b sıfır diyor. a çarpı b
sıfır ise
şimdi durumları gösteren mevzuya geldim.
Şimdi o diyordu ki a çarpı b'yi bir
incele. Ben de yazdım. Bak matematikçeye
çevirdim. Şurada yazılanları
matematikçeye yazdım. a b eleman r için
a çarpı b sıfır ise
kardeş burada tek bir durum var. Yani
daha doğrusu şöyle bir şey var. En az
biri sıfır olmalı değil mi? En az biri.
Bak. a sıfır olabilir. Tamam kabul.
b sıfır olabilir. Kabul. İkisi de sıfır
olabilir. Kabul.
Oğlum bu kadar yumuşak kalpli bir bağlaç
nerede var?
Aynen öyle. Veya bağlacında var. O zaman
ben bu işi şöyle yazarım. Derim ki a
eşittir sıfır veya b eşittir sıfır.
Mevzu bu kadar.
Mantığı kavradık mı? Matematikçeye yazma
olayını. Hadi beşe de bakalım. Pratik
olsun.
İki negatif gerçek sayının çarpımı
pozitif bir gerçek sayıdır önermesini
sembolik dil ile ifade edeceğiz.
Şimdi sen bana diyorsun ki bütün
diyorsun, her diyorsun.
İki tane bana harf atın. x ve y olsun. x
ve y gerçek sayı diyorsun. Tamam
elemanıdır gerçek sayı diyorum. Her x y
elemanı pardon negatif gerçek sayı
demiş. Özürs. Hemen eksimi de çakarım.
Eksi r gerçek sayı. Yani negatif gerçek
sayı. Tamam.
Bunların çarpımı yani bunlar için her x
y negatif
reel sayılardan aldığım her x y için
negatif olarak
çarpımı demiş. Yani ne yazacağım? x
çarpı y
büyüktür sıfır diyeceğim. Pozitifi biz
nasıl söyleriz gençler? Sıfırdan büyük
sayı demektir. O yüzden büyüktür sıfır
dedim. Bitti.
Bu kadar. Sembolik dille yazdım. Bundan
sonrası tatava. Geçtim 6. soruma.
Şimdi bakın, bu soru birazcık değişik,
garip bir soru. Bakalım. Bir öğretmen
demiş, "Üçgenin kenar uzunlukları ile
üçgenin çeşitleri arasındaki ilişkiyi
açıklayan bir algoritmanın akış şemasını
aşağıdaki gibi çizmiş." Şimdi bakın,
böyle bir akış şeması olduğunda, hani
mevzu algoritma diye de çok hani
kafanızdaki matematiği de resetlemeyin
bir zahmet, tamam mı? Bütün matematik
bilgilerini unutmayın. Bir bakın, ne
anlatıyor? Matematik
dilinde ne anlaşılıyor, anlatılıyor
burada? Bir bakalım.
Şimdi demiş ki, "Önce başla." Başladım.
"A, B, C kenarlarının uzunluklarını
santimetre cinsinden al."
A, B, C kenar uzunluklarını al. He,
üçgenle ilgili bir şey yapıyoruz. Hatta
bak yukarıda da aslında söylüyor. Kenar
uzunlukları ile üçgenin çeşitleri
arasındaki ilişkiyi inceleyecek bu
algoritma.
Tamam.
Şimdi burada bir önerme var. İşte, daha
doğrusu eşitsizlik var. A
toplamlarından küçük, farklarından büyük
mevzusu. Aa, bu üçgen eşitsizliği değil
mi ya? Kenarlarına göre bakacak. Hatta
bu eşitsizlik sağlanmıyorsa, sen diyor
bir yürü git diyor. Hani bizim
yanımızdan ayrıl, çünkü üçgen
oluşturmazsın. Algoritmayı kapat diyor.
Fişi çek.
Tamam? Dolayısıyla kenarlarını bana
uygun vermelisin, üçgen eşitsizliğine
göre. Tamam? Ondan sonra da işte
eşkenar, ikizkenar bir şeyler çıkacak.
Oraya bakarız. Soru ne? Benden ne
isteniyor? Akış şemasında kullanılan
mantık bağlaçlarını belirleyiniz diyor.
Şimdi, bağlaç belirleyeceğiz.
Direkt yazmamış. Direkt yazsa onu 1.
sınıfa soruyoruz zaten.
Direkt yazıp hemen gördüğünü alsın,
cevaba yazsın. O 1. sınıf işi.
Sen 9. sınıf olarak
kendin birazcık çözümleyeceksin.
Şimdi bir kere dakika bir gol bir.
Kardeş, burada
iki taraflı bir kesinlik isteniyor,
değil mi?
Yani A kenarı diyor, herhangi bir kenar,
hem diyor toplamlarından küçük olacak
hem de farklardan büyük olacak. Aynı
anda olacak. Hani hocam bu olsa bu ol,
aa ikisi de olacak. Aa bu kadar sert, bu
kadar asabi bir bağlaç kim olabilir?
Tabii ki de ve bağlacı. Tamam mı? Hatta
bunu şimdiden söyleyelim mi? İkinci
sorunun da cevabı olacak. Mantık
bağlaçlarından birinin algoritmada ki
işleyişinin rolünü açıklayınız demiş.
Ben burada kimi açıklayacağım? En kolayı
ve bağlacı.
Burada ve bağlacı beni nerede,
daha doğrusu bana nerede iş görüyor,
nerede bunu
görebiliyorum, açıklayabiliyorum? Ve
bağlacı
nerede diyelim? Üçgen eşitsizliğinde
eşitsizlik kısmında daha doğrusu üçgen
eşitsizlik kısmında
rol oynamış yazabilirsin. Ben doktorca
yazımı yazdım orada bırakıyorum. Daha da
fazla doktorca yazabilirim ama o zaman
kimse okuyamaz. Tamam mı? Şimdi ve
bağlacını yazdık. Hatta birazcık
matematikçe yapalım ya. Ve bağlacı al.
Bu şekil sembolle geldim.
Şimdi başka başka. Gençler bir de ne var
biliyor musunuz? Aslında akış şemasının
tamamında gördüğümüz bir ise bağlacı
var.
İse burada
her karar düğümünü aslında birbirine
bağlıyor. Mesela burada a eşittir b evet
ise buraya
hayır ise bu tarafa git. Dolayısıyla
burada kesinlikle bir ise bağlacı
kullanıldığını de söyleyebilirim.
Son bir tane daha var. O da şu. Tabii ki
de olmaz yumuşak kalpler ne olacak?
Nedir? Veya bağlacı. Şimdi biz veya
bağlacını aslında farklı yolların
aynı kapıya çıkmasında görebiliyoruz.
Mesela ikizkenar üçgen. E şimdi
ikizkenar üçgen için sadece bu yoldan mı
geliyorsun? Hayır, bak buradan da
gelebiliyormuşsun.
Hatta buradan da gelebiliyormuşsun. Ha o
zaman burada bir yumuşak kalplilik var.
Bunu aklında böyle tutabilirsin. Hani
oradan da gelebiliyor, buradan da
gelebiliyor. Ha o zaman orada bir veya
bağlaç kullanımından
söz edebiliriz. Tamam? Mevzu anlaşıldı
mı? Bak, mesela A = B. Eğer evet
diyorsan
B = C'ye de hayır diyorsan, yani A B
sadece iki tane kenar eşit. A o zaman
ikizkenar diyebiliyoruz. Ama A = B'ye
mesela hayır diyebilirsin. O zaman A = C
mi? Eğer buna evet diyorsan yine sen iki
kenara evet dedin, o zaman ikizkenar
üçgene çıkıyoruz yine.
Yine çıkıyoruz. Yani bir oradan
gelebilir, bir buradan. Bunu nerede
göreceğim? Her yerden böyle birden fazla
farklı yollardan aynı kapıya çıkıyorsam
yumuşak kalpten de var. Tamam?
Şimdi bağlaçlar,
niceleyiciler mevzusu bu.
Sana nereden soru gelecek? Yine
söylüyorum, şu 4 ve 5. sorudan kesin
gelecek.
2. soru gelecek. Tamam mı?
Bunlara bir bakalım. Yazılıdan önce
mutlaka bakalım. Anlaştık?
Şimdi gelelim kitabınızda çok çok fazla
yer almasa da önemli bir mevzu, tüketme
yaklaşımı ve Kadane algoritması. Şimdi
bu mevzu nedir? Menü Hoca bunun yine
abidik gubidik yöntemlerini bulmuştur.
Tamam, bize böyle saçma sapan yerlerden
dalış yaparak anlatır diyeceksin. Evet.
Şimdi bir kere oğlum bunlar çok
ciddi
zihinlerde
alev alan, alev aldırmaya sebep olan
yerler. Gerçekten sağlam
algoritmalar bunlar. Tamam? Kadane
galiba kendi adını vermiş hatta. Adam o
yani.
Tamam, ben buldum, başkasına yedirir
miyim kafasında.
Şimdi
gençler, bunun mevzusu ne biliyor
musunuz?
Ben sana kısaca şöyle söyleyeyim. Sen
şimdi bak sınıfa girdin. Öğretmenin,
öğrenciler işte sana bir sürpriz
yapmışlar.
Öğretmen beş altı tane diyelim, altı
öğrenciyi tahtaya çıkartıyor. Hepsinin
de boynuna bir tane kağıt asıyor, tamam
mı? Bak şimdi, olayın neden bu konuyu
gördüğünü anla.
Anlaştık mı? Önce mantığını anlatıyorum,
sonra nasıl yapıldığını anlatacağım.
Neden bunu görüyoruz? Nedeni şu, sen
sınıfa girdin, öğretmen ve öğrenciler
sana sürpriz yapıyorlar. Öğretmen
kaldırmış öğrencileri, hepsinin boynunda
bir kağıt, böyle kurbanlık dana gibi,
hepsinde künye var, tamam [kahkaha] mı?
Orada üstlerinde sayılar yazıyor. Altı
öğrencinin üstünde sayı yazıyor. Bu ne
sayılar? Cebindeki para olabilir ya da
borcu olabilir. Mesela
sırayla birinci öğrencide atıyorum
yedi yazıyor. O ne demek? Yedi lirası
var anlamında demek, tamam?
Sonra hemen yanındaki ikinci öğrencide
eksi dört yazıyor. Bu da onun dört lira
borcu var demek.
Şimdi öğretmen sana diyor ki, sana
sürpriz hazırlamışlar.
Nazlıcan,
>> [kahkaha]
>> Güllüşah, sana eee
bir oyun sunuyoruz.
Şimdi bu arkadaşların arasında, altı
öğrenci tahtada dizili,
ardışık olarak bir grup seç ve o grubun
sayılarının toplamı kadar parayı sana
vereceğiz diyor.
Ha.
Şimdi bak, sen ne yapabilirsin? Mesela
şu örnekten hatta anlatayım. Mesela
yediyi alabilirsin hemen. Hocam ben yedi
liramı alıp gideyim. Hani bir sakız
alırım falan.
Hani burada mantığı anlayın.
Yediyi alabilirsin. Ya da şöyle, bak
şunu yapma hakkın yok ama, hocam buradan
yediyi alayım, buradan üçü alayım,
buradan ikiyi alayım. Hayır. Ardışık
seçeceksin. İkili grup seç, tekli grup
seç, üçlü grup seç, fark etmez. Hepsini
seç, o da olur. Ama ardışık olacak. Yani
sırayla olacak. Hepsini aldın mı zaten
hepsi sırayla, hepsini almış olursun.
Ama belki de bunların hepsinin toplamı
yedi yapmayabilir, bak. Zararlı
çıkarsın. Hadi böyle bir açgözlü
kafasıyla dalarsan işin içine, hocam ben
tümünü hepsini alıyorum. O zaman ne olur
bak biliyor musun? Şurası üç, iki daha
beş, üç daha sekiz, şunu çıkarttım 3.
Bir topladım 4 alırsın bak mesela.
Halbuki sadece birinci öğrenciyi
alıyorum desen 7. Ama belki de öyle bir
grup var ki, mesela atıyorum ikinci,
üçüncü, dördüncü şunu seçtin. Belki de
7'den fazla çıkacak.
Olayın mantığını anladık mı?
Sıralı öğrenci seçeceğiz ve en büyük
sayıyı yakalamak istiyoruz. Toplamada en
büyük sayıyı yakalamak istiyoruz. Tamam,
olay anlaşıldı.
Şimdi bunun için iki yaklaşım var.
Birincisi tüketme yaklaşımı. Bunu çok
hızlı geçeceğim. Çünkü bu aslında
neden Kadane algoritmasını
kullanıyoruzun cevabı. Çünkü bununla
çözmeye çalışırsak 1 yıl sürer, bununla
çözmeye çalışırsak 1 dakika sürecek.
Yani Kadane böyle bir olayı halletmiş.
Şimdi tüketme yaklaşımı şu gençler.
Tüketme yaklaşımında elde edilen
toplamalardan, hani bak biz de toplamak
istiyoruz ya, en büyüğünü bulmak için
bir döngü kullanır. Bu döngüde kümenin
her elemanını birer birer ele alarak
toplamları hesaplar ve karşılaştırır.
Şimdi hemen örnekten de gideceğim.
Burada bir sayı grubu var. İşte tahtaya
çıkan 6 öğrenci var. Burada herhangi bir
elemandan başlayarak birbiri ardına
gelen elemanların toplamlarını
hesaplayıp en büyük olanın tüketme
yaklaşımını Kadane ile bulunuz diyor.
Tüketme ile yapalım önce. Şimdi ne
yaparsın? Sen yani bilmiyorsun Kadane
algoritması falan. Cahil, tamam mı?
Cahilsin.
Ayıp değil. Öğrenmemek ayıp. Şimdi
burada tek tek sayarsın. Dersin ki lan
ben birinci öğrenciyi alsam 7 eşittir 7.
Yani 7 lira alırım.
Birinci, ikinciyi alsam, ha o zaman 7
artı eksi 4'ten 3. Hayda, bu beni çok
şey yapmadı, sarmadı. Birinci, ikinci,
üçüncüyü alayım. Mesela şöyle yaptın.
Eksi 4 ve ikinci, üçüncüyü de aldın.
Yani şöyle üçlü grup aldın, tamam mı?
Bunu hesapladın. İşte bir 5 oldu. Sonra
işte diğerini aldın, bir daha
hesapladın. Bir sonrakini aldın, hepsini
aldın. Eee, ben bunları yapayım ya, dur.
Yedi
eksi dört, tamam mı? İkiyi aldım, bir de
diğer öğrenciyi aldık, üçü, sekiz yaptı.
Bak, bak sekizi bulduk işte. Gördün mü
bak işte? Bunu bulmayı öğreneceğiz.
Belki ama bir sekizden de daha büyüğü
var, nereden biliyorsun? Sonra işte eksi
beş eklenecek. Bu şu kısma denden
koyuyorum, artı eksi beş, mı?
Matematikte de böyle işlem, ya başka
yerde göremezsin.
O yüzden sen de yapma, sadece mevzuyu
anla. Buradan üç mü geliyor? Sonra
buraya denden koyup en son biri yazan
arkadaşı da ekleyelim, dört geliyor
mesela. Tamam? Yani böyle böyle tek tek
toplayacaksın. Sonra bunu kapatacaksın.
Tamam mı? Şunu kapatıyorsun.
Eee, tüketme yaklaşımı böyle. Birinciden
başlamıştın, belki de ikinciden
başlayınca olacak. Eksi dört ile
başlayacaksın, eksi dört. Sonra eksi
dördün yanına iki ekleyeceksin, işte
artı iki. Sonra eksi dördün yanına iki
eklemiştin ya, bak, sırasıyla. Sonra bir
de üçü ekleyeceksin.
Ne gelecek? Beş. Eksi dördün yanına iki
eklemiştin, sonra üç eklemiştin, sonra
da eksi beşi ekle bakalım. Eksi beşi de
ekleyince buradan sıfır. Sonra eksi
dördün yanına, ikinin yanına, üçün
yanına, bir de eksi beşin yanına, en son
arkadaş biri de eklediğinde biri
çıkacak. Bla bla bla bla. Melih hocaya
bunu
mümkün değil doldurtamazsınız, tamam mı?
Sen doldur.
Maksat mevzuyu anladın mı? Ben bu
amelelikle uğraşmayacağım. O sizin
işiniz.
Boşuna mı okuduk yıllarca, dirsek
çürüttük? Şimdi
tüketme yaklaşımı bu gençler. Tek tek
bulmaya yönelik ve hani altı tane sayı
olsa hadi halledersin, yüz tane sayı
olursa orada bilgisayar patlar.
Dolayısıyla Kadane algoritması diye bir
şey var. Şimdi onu anlatacağım.
Verilen sayı kümesindeki ardışık
elemanların, bak yine işimiz ardışık
olması,
toplanması ile elde edilen toplam lardan
değeri en büyük olanını bulmak için
Kadane algoritması kullanılabilir. Gel
şimdi Kadane algoritmasına bakalım.
Şimdi ne demiştik? Öğrenciler çıktı ve
kurbanlık dana gibi burada künye vardı
değil mi? Hah, danadan yola çıkarak
şimdi ben sana MÖ kuralı anlatacağım.
MÖ kuralı, tamam?
Amacımız ne? Maksimumu bulmak.
Maksimumun M'sini aldım. Ö de önceki
toplamlardan aklına gelsin.
Şimdi gençler, bana ilk sayıyı söyler
misiniz? Kadane algoritması yapıyoruz.
İlk sayımız kim? 7. Tamam mı? O zaman
birinci adımda ben 7'yi alırım.
Hatta şöyle yapacağız bak, dur. Onu uzun
uzun yapacağım.
Sayıları gençler öncelikle şöyle yan
yana şey alt alta yazın. Yan yana
nereden çıktı ya? Şöyle tek tek hepsini
alt alta yazın. Yanlarına da maksimum ve
önceki toplam diye şöyle MÖ harflerimizi
yazalım. Yani öğretmen seni tahtaya
kaldırdı.
Tabii ki de MÖ kuralı diye bir şey yok.
Bak bir daha söylüyorum, beni rezil
etmeyin sağda solda. Bu tamamen sen daha
iyi anla diye benim uydurduğum bir şey.
M ve Ö ama şey değil hani kafamdan
atmadım yani. Mantıklı bir şekilde
sadece birazcık böyle
entertainment yapıyoruz, tamam?
Şimdi birinci sayımızı aldık, 7.
Maksimumumuz kaç şu an? Elimizdeki en
büyük sayı 7. E önceki Ö'ye de yine
yazacağım, 7 yazacağım. Yani önceki diye
bir şey yok çünkü 7'yi aynen
alıyorsunuz.
Şimdi ikinci sayı geldi. Yani birinci
öğrenciyi gördün, ikinci öğrencinin
künyesinde ne yazıyor? -4. Şimdi
yapacağın şey şu.
sayını yaz.
-4'ü yaz.
2 -4'le bir öncekini toplayıp yaz. Ne
yapıyor toplam? 3 yapıyor.
Ve üçüncü olarak da şu ana kadar
gördüğün en büyük sayıyı yaz. Şu ana
kadar gördüğüm en büyük toplam 7'ydi.
Şimdi bu üçünden bana söyle, maksimum
kim? 7'dir. O zaman senin maksimumun
değişmedi.
Diğer ikisinde de en büyük kim kalıyor?
Üç mü kalıyor? O zaman önceki kısmına da
üç yazıyorsun. Yani aslında bununla
öncekinin toplanması üçtür ya, oradan
geliyor.
Şimdi -4'ü hallettik. Bak, 7'yi, -4'ü
hallettim. Şimdi 2'ye geldim. Bak, ne
yapıyorduk?
Sayını yaz.
Sayıyı öncekiyle topla. 2 3 daha 5.
Sonra bugüne kadar gördüğün maksimumunu
yaz. 7.
Şimdi bana söyle bakayım. Maksimum kaç?
En büyük sayı? 7. Aa, 7 değişmedi. Hemen
oraya yazalım. Peki,
bu diğer ikisi arasından en büyük kim?
5. O zaman 5'i alıyorsun. Yani bu o, şu
demek aslında. Önceden gördüğün,
öncekilerden gördüğün en büyük sayı kaç?
Onun gibi düşünebilirsin.
Bunu da yazdım.
Şimdi geldim 3'e. Bak, 2'yi de
hallettik. Şimdi sayımı yazıyorum. 3.
Bir öncekiyle toplam 8. Aha, bizim max
geldi.
Eee, ne yazıyorduk? Sayımızı yazdık.
Öncekiyle toplamı yazdık ve elimizde şu
ana kadarki maksimumu yazıyoruz. 7.
Şimdi bakın.
Burada, üçlüde
maksimum kim? 8. Bak, benim maksimumum
7'ydi ama artık ne gördüm ben? 8 gördüm.
Dolayısıyla maksimum değiştiği anda
önceki değer kısmı da değişir.
Çünkü şöyle düşün. Sen artık 8'i gördün
ya,
ondan önce gördüğün düşük sayılar
umrunda olmaz. Dolayısıyla maksimuma da
öncekilere de 8 yaz.
Yani yeni gördüğün maksimum değerini
yazıyorsun.
Geçtim -5'e. Şimdi sıradaki sayım geldi.
-5.
Ne yazıyordum? Sayımı yazıyordum. -5.
Daha önce, eee, -5'in öncekiyle
toplamını yazıyorum. -5 8 daha 3. Daha
önce gördüğüm maksimum kim? 8. Bana
bunların içinden maksimumu söyler misin?
En büyük kim? Sekiz. Hala max değişmedi.
Eee, diğer ikisi arasındaki en büyük
kim? Üç. Yani önceden gördüğüm en büyük
sayı gibi de düşünebilirsin. Üçü yazdım.
Şimdi
geliyorum bire.
Bunu da hallettim. Biri yazıyorum.
Öncekiyle toplam dört. Bugüne kadar
gördüğüm maksimum sekiz. En büyüğü söyle
bana, sekiz. Max yine değişmedi. Bundan
sonrakilerin büyüğü de dört. Buraya da
dört yazdım ama daha devam etmeyeceğim.
Dolayısıyla lafı uzatmaya gerek yok. En
büyük arkadaşımız sekizmiş. Tamam mı?
Hatta bunu nerede görüyoruz? Bak, sekizi
nerede yakaladık? Az önce yakalamıştık
aslında. Şurada. Yedi, eksi dört, iki ve
üç. Yani şu dörtlü grubu aldığımda, yani
öğretmen seni tahtaya çıkartmıştı ya,
ardışık arkadaşlarından seç, maksimum
parayı kazan dedi.
Birinciyi seçip yedi lira alabilirdin
ama o doğru cevap değil. Maksimum değil.
Birinci, ikinci, üçüncü ve dördüncü
arkadaşları alıyorum dediğin anda en
fazla parayı elde etmiş oluyorsun.
Mantığı anladık yani, değil mi? Hani
sebebini anladık, değil mi?
Biz bu işi niye yapıyoruz? Sebebini
anladıktan sonra da şu yaklaşımı
bir daha izle, son on dakikayı, iyice
oturtacaksın. O zaman ne diyorum? Melih
Hoca'dan mevzu
burada biter. Tamam mı? Evet, sevgili
dokuzuncu sınıflar, 27. dersimizin
sonuna geldim.
Eee, buradaki dediğim gibi daha da
pekiştirmek için bak, uygula, pekiştir
ve yazılı sorularımız var. Kaymak gibi,
cillop gibi sorular. Mutlaka çözün.
Eee, bunları çözüp bir de çözüm
videolarını da izlediğinde daha da
akılda kalıcı olacak, daha iyi
anlayacaksınız. Onu söyleyebilirim.
Eee, yazılı sorularımız da bak, tam
yazılıda çıkacak sorular ya. Şemalar,
tüketme yaklaşımı var falan.
Tam böyle
yüz aldıracak kitap.
Bundan sonra tek, eee, dersimiz var,
algoritma ile ilgili 28. dersimiz kaldı.
Orada da ispat yapacağız. Tek sayfa. Tek
sayfalık dersimiz var ama içerik
içerik tek sayfaya
eee, rahmet okutur öyle söyleyeyim.
Ondan sonra da artık 6. temamıza geçiş
yapacağız sevgili 9. sınıflar.
Eh, hadi bakalım o zaman. Kapanış
İstiklal Marşı ve kapanış diyelim.
Ne diyoruz? Bir sonraki ders yeniden
görüşünceye dek, kendinize çok iyi bakın
ve matematikle kalın. Hoşça kalın.
>> Artık [müzik] yön matematik
herkes için kolaylık.
>> [müzik]
>> Sen de katıl bu öğretme eğlence dolu
pratik